here in the wedding capital of the world
in Las Vegas the month of February
historically proves that we are
extremely busy now we are not only is
Valentine's Day bringing more weddings
it's bringing billions of dollars here
to the valley and uh what's more
romantic than an airport terminal now we
should point out just the paperwork's
happening at the airport right of course
Ryan Matthew joining us live there at
the pop-up marriage license bureau in
Harry Reid International because there's
a lot of folks who want to tie the knot
during February hi Ryan
yeah Denise Bryant this is probably one
of the most Vegas things you can do hop
off your flight pick up your bags
conveniently just get your marriage
license and head on down to a chapel to
get married and as Vegas is growing so
is its wedding industry
foreign I do want to get married in Las
Vegas this month I'm like why China and
they're like we watch you on TLC all the
time I'm like okay so do thousands of
others sweatadar is prepping the famed
little white wedding chapel for the
local out of state and international
lovers heading their way we are
expecting a lot of walk-ins because we
are getting these calls that every 15
minutes we are checking on your website
and everything is full you know they're
packed outside the doors where we can't
even shut the door little Church of the
West the oldest Clark County Chapel
marked the Valley's rise to wedding
capital of the world nearly a century
later it's grown to a two and a half
billion dollar industry leading up to
Valentine's Day and the day itself 1500
marriage license on average given out
they think about weddings they're like
hey you know we're here for a Raiders
game Let's uh let's go down and get
married Vegas wedding chamber president
and Elvis impersonator Brian Mills says
the Valley's growth marries well with
the industry people can come here they
can have an entire wedding and a
reception and have entertain payment and
have attractions now they can go to
sporting events all different things
that Vegas offers can be included in
with weddings but it'll cost you both on
Valentine's Day or other special dates
this year two three two three several
chapels keep the same price year round
ranging from a couple hundred dollars
the most would be about eight hundred to
one thousand dollars per wedding because
they have Elvis they have like the
chapel they purchase all the merchandise
still a fraction of the price it may
cost doing it back home our slow season
has now progressively gotten less and
less because people are just coming here
for other things and deciding to get
married while they're here
yeah
they add Val renewals also a huge driver
of business during this month and
tomorrow to 323 little white wedding
chapels already scheduled 80 weddings
for tomorrow that does not include the
expected walk-ins that they anticipated
in Valentine's Day get this 200 weddings
back to back all throughout their
12-hour shift
talk about romance right reporting live
here at Harry Reid International Ryan
Matthey a news now Ryan thanks for that
and the Clark County Clerk expecting to
hand out almost a thousand licenses just
at the airport pop-up